AND THE KINGS?
KENNY: BOTH TEAMS
LAST GAME ON SUNDAY. MA.
CENTERING PASS.
BACK DOWN AND THATO
AVOIR MATHEWS.
AUSTON MATHEWS DOWN
LOW. OUTLOOK PASS.
HERE COMES
UNDER
KENNY?OLCZYK, KEITH
ACKNOWLEDGING THAT.
KENNY: 42 GOALS BACK
IN LOOKING FOR
IT.
T KOPITAR HERE.
YOU BROUGHT UP PHIL
BY KOPITAR
ABLE TO TIP IT IN.
JUST A GREAT PLAY TO
SEE THIT.
GETS INSIDE, A
LITTLE CURL AND
DRAG, JOJO NOT.
KENNY: HERE'S
IAFALLO.
HITTING THE KNOB OF
THE STICK OF THE
GOALTENDER.
YOU CAN SEE OF THE PERI.
I DON'T THINK HE
LIKED THE CALL OF
THE NET.
WE TALKED ABOUT IT,
ARVIDSSON TIED IT IN
THE SECOND AND THEN
TWO MORE LEAFS GOALS
EDDIE: MATHEWS
BATTLING KOPITAR.
MATHEWS OUT IN
FRONT.
MATHEWS SCOR
UP HIGH ENOUGH TO
NYLANDER.
KENNY: AWESOME IN ND MA
LEAFS GO TO WORK VETERA.
>> SO JONATHAN QUICKAYS FROM SU
STAR TALENT LIKE
NYLANDER GO ALONG
WAY.K WAS
TALKING ABOUT THOSE
CROSS PASSES THAT
ARE SO DIFFICULT TO
DURZI, HE SCORES!
HIS SECOND
I LOVE HOW HE
CELEBRATES.
>> THIS KID GETS
TOMORROW.
>> SAME HERE.
>> WATCH